the f word feminism Oh I thought yeah
the reason why men are finding women
over in the west versus I think it's
alienates is feminism yeah I think it
alienates 100 I think it gives um
I think it gives women a false kind of
um
sense of entitlement and I think that
it makes them feel like victims even
though they probably weren't even alive
whether times
exactly so they don't even know what
really happened and I think that um it
makes them feel like the victim so it
gives them the right to act a certain
way and treat men a certain way and it's
it's quite sad really because I think we
both lose it's because we're feminism
allowed women to be bailed out of every
single bad decision that we make ever
like if you want to if we wanna sleep
around there's birth control yeah if
that doesn't work we have abortion if
that doesn't work you can get um
government assistance for being a single
mother
um if that doesn't work
um you can you know marry someone it
does could be the father of your kid
could not
um and then you know leave him and take
half yeah
[Laughter]
I did not get a penny again
and then and then on top of that like um
foreign
I mean men you know commit like suicide
a lot of times after these divorces so a
lot of times like women make bad
decisions at the expense of man it also
allows us if we want to be homeless
there's women's shelters too there's
actually um for this hospitals for men
as well
there's a friend of mine
there was a friend of mine who was in
Iran and he was talking to this uh lady
who's like the Auntie of his wife a
woman that he was about to marry and she
said how many houses do you have in in
England he said I'll just have the one
house it was really you only have one
house I have two houses he said yeah
that's because I didn't get divorced
twice
[Laughter]
what do you think um with the beautiful
majestic creatures
they say it's like Cheaper to Keep Her
Like why yes yes like why is that a
phrase yeah it's true so feminism is one
of the reasons I think why the men are
flocking to outside of the West feminism
is messed up it also confuses um women
about like what men actually want I mean
how many I've had girls on the show that
like genuinely think that men care about
your job they don't give a [ __ ] and they
don't care about body count so yeah no
they actually do care about your body
and we don't care about your job
yeah do you know what I mean I mean I
mean I think
how many girls clothes that have called
Liz who at 10.
what were you gonna say go ahead no I
was gonna say that like obviously if
you're dating in your like your pool and
you've got an amazing job job then
surely you you want a partner that like
matches you in some math work so your
job not necessarily I don't know I'm not
a man so maybe not maybe not all men but
I think I think the demographic men who
want their women to actually be
successful successful in some days
I don't care about a woman's job what
she does but I want it to not be not
involve her being naked or anything like
that yeah and I want it to be something
that she enjoys
um and
that's about it really yeah like uh you
know that's it but there's still a level
and I wanted to have one it would be
nice if she has one yeah so it's like
women like we're attracted to the CEO of
a company like I've used this example
before but Donald Trump and Melania okay
I don't I'm not talking about politics
but who's better looking him or him or
Melania right she's better looking and
it's not the same thing for Oprah
like there aren't men lining up to bang
Oprah but there's there's I'm sure
Donald Trump even look Donald Trump even
looking how he does has women lined up I
just like this I just like to say Oprah
if you ever see this I am willing to get
there
but we can maybe put it on like payment
plan so maybe at her credit card
no I I think like I said when it comes
to feminism like
the reason why you know men are opting
out like women you've done many Street
interviews Perl when you've asked women
about like body count does body count
matter and they're like nobody count
doesn't matter because if a man worries
about body count then he's a it's like
yeah this is why I'm gonna run this is
why men are going outside because body
count matters yeah yeah it doesn't
matter to women sometimes I get it but
to men 100 yeah because I fully believe
that I mean even if a man tells you I
don't care about it just tell me as soon
as you tell them
do not tell him this is how I know it
matters because if there's a woman that
I think is amazing
I probably won't ask
if she's that amazing but the problem is
with that body count come certain
behaviors and habits and and also ethics
I think and and morals and that will
permeate through your relationship so
you may not know her brother
I think I've got a really good barometer
for that I can tell well you know so
yeah
I can pretty much tell I think most guys
can tell if someone's uh
had a lot of people
I don't know how can you tell how can
you be surprised it's a feeling it's an
attitude and a lot of the time those
women tend to be less feminine actually
funnily enough
well I think because every it's like
every body there's more trauma exactly
and so and no just being real like
unless you're unless you're the type of
girl that doesn't attach right which I
don't think men typically want
um like there's more trauma with each
guy you're with and so that's why guys
can smell a high body count
energetically you also like the shot
smells blood trust me every time you're
with somebody you're taking on their
energy I mean for me I do think
sometimes people have had many lives in
a sense of you you can get someone that
you know has had a high body count but
they've they've completely kind of
turned that around and they're not like
that anymore
I think
but I was like Dad do you think like
people change over time and he says yes
they get worse so whatever Behavior you
see that you don't like like it's gonna
be worse yes
and I just think like you can you can
hide it and some simp won't see it but
if you have like you're gonna have
behaviors that are going to show you
show him exactly what like what you are
and I just don't think like you can hide
it forever yeah like it's hard to be
like you said five I just heard about
this sex
yeah I said might allow it because they
don't think they can do better yeah yeah
that's what happens quite often if you
had like 30 dicks inside you right and
like
you're gonna like a guy will eventually
see that you've had 30 dicks inside you
you will eventually because the thing is
your like you said your behaviors will
show it
the thing is that that is that is why
women who have had most women who have
had more than what five bodies are more
likely to get divorced or your chance
your chance to have a happy marriage and
okay people don't like this study so
there's a couple different ones but
um if you're a virgin on your wedding
night you have an 80 chance of a happy
marriage there's a couple studies that
say 60 to 70 percent so it depends which
one but it drops to a 25 chance after
like five to seven Partners so you're
basically ruined after like five to
seven because yeah because you're okay
because you're comparing your guy with a
consciously or subconsciously to those
guys and you're like was he like that
was he like that guy is he like that guy
for me for me an analogy of the body
counting for women is it's kind of like
um when you first get on the internet
and you check the comment sections and
you see all the people talking bad about
you and giving you more and more [ __ ]
eventually you desensitize to it you
become you know you harden effectively
and you no longer get affected as much
by the comment section as you used to
when you first did and that is the same
with women who have more and more
Partners is eventually you're you are
not because you get hurt you get
heartbroken you this is a coping
mechanism within a human being they
don't want to be hurt anymore and your
body will figure out a way to protect
you from being hurt and that will mean
usually you will become more of a
distant person and you will never fully
commit yourself to a to the next
relationship because you know that the
previous one really hurts so now you
also know the one that felt really good
the alpha Widow as well you know the one
that felt really good and you're like as
many of you know I I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible